Hey there, space explorers!
Today, you and the Peanuts gang will
take on three exciting S.T.E.M. missions
inspired by Snoopy in Space.
Collecting space samples,
building a stellar satellite,
and crafting moon sand.
I can’t go to space!
I don’t have my toothbrush!
Feel free to attempt all of them,
or just your favorite.
It’s up to you and your team!
So, gather the parts you’ll need,
grab a grown-up to help,
and get ready to blast off.
Are we ready to launch?
Ready!
[Snoring]
Sir? Sir!
Present!
Mission One: Galaxy Slime
The galaxy is pretty big.
All: Woah!
First, gather your materials.
A ½ cup of clear glue,
a ½ cup of water,
a ½ cup of liquid cornstarch,
food coloring,
glitter and confetti stars,
and a large bowl and spoon
to mix it all together.
First, mix the water and glue in your bowl.
Next, add a drop or two
of your favorite food coloring,
and plenty of glitter and stars.
Now, add the liquid cornstarch
and stir until there’s no liquid left.
Your bowl should now be
totally full of galaxy slime!
Woo-hoo! Yeah!
Start experimenting with your galaxy slime
by kneading and playing with it.
You should notice the slime feeling different
the more you play with it.
How far can you stretch it?
I can’t wait to see what
discoveries they’ve made!
Like all the aliens
they’re hiding in the basement?
Good grief.
Our next mission is Preflight Satellite.
Now I’m hoping to get a transmission
from even farther in space!
Here’s what you’ll need:
a juice box,
some sponges,
a few pipe cleaners,
a pick-up stick,
a paper straw,
a Styrofoam ball,
black construction paper,
washers & bolts,
tape,
and, finally, scissors.
So, what do we do now?
Let’s start building!
First, wrap the juice box
in your favorite colorful paper.
A juice box makes a great container
for all your scientific instruments.
In this section, we’re going to be
working with safety scissors.
So, grab an adult and have them
cut the sponges into three pieces.
The sponges will make perfect solar panels
to soak up sunlight.
Now, run the pipe cleaners
through each sponge,
and then into the juice box.
If you need help making holes
in the juice box,
ask an adult!
Tilt the sponges,
or your satellite’s panels,
to capture maximum sunlight power.
All: Ooh! Woah!
Now, it’s time to
assemble your communications
by having an adult cut
the Styrofoam ball in half.
And they can also cut a small circle of
black construction paper for you.
And glue it to the flat surface of the foam.
Then, take a small part of the straw
and stick it through the black paper
into the foam.
Creating a communication dish!
Grab a pick-up stick
and push one end into the foam,
and the other into the top of the juice box.
Now your satellite can
stay in contact with ground control!
Snoopy, do you copy?
To make sure your satellite
doesn’t get lost,
it’ll need an orientation tracker
to keep an eye on the stars.
Your washers will be
the perfect trackers
once you tape them to the box.
Time to launch and
drift through space!
[Everyone cheers]
Our final mission is critical.
Crater Creator.
Ooh!
Here’s what you’ll need
to create some moon sand craters:
2 ½ cups of colorful sand,
glitter,
1 ½ cups of cornstarch,
¾ cup of canola oil,
and a large mixing bowl and spoon.
What are we waiting for?
Okay, step one -
pour all of your sand into a bowl.
We’re combining blue and black sand,
but use any colors you like
and mix it up!
Step two,
slowly add in the cornstarch
one or two spoonfuls at a time.
Step three,
slowly pour in the canola oil.
And step four is the most fun!
Add glitter,
and mix it all together.
Next, grab an adult and transfer
your moon sand to
a new container if you’d like.
Add craters, mountains, canyons,
and colorful decorations!
It never hurts to add more glitter, too!
Now you and your team
have your very own moonscape to explore.
[Snoopy yells]
Great job today!
[Cheering]
Great work, everyone!
Now you have all the tools
to make any mission a success.
[Cheering]
I’m swept up in the moment!
All that’s left
is to get out and explore.
Our solar system is a
vast and wonderous place.
Snoopy in Space: The Search for Life.